my name is Sheila Patel and the director
of an NGO in India that works with the
social movements of the oven / called
spark but I'm also the chair of an
international organization collect well
as international in which community
networks of slum dwellers in Asia Africa
and Latin America meet to produce a
voice that addresses the issues of
informality and slums in cities so when
I looked at the topics that have been
given priority definitely the issue of
water youth women critically important
infrastructure critically important but
nobody in this forum has addressed the
relationship between the growth of
cities in the next ten years and the
increasing in formality in which people
live and work in Africa and the
criminalization and the lack of safety
that exists in these cities the cities
of Africa are going to be the first
contact between Africa and the rest of
the world if growth proceeds the way it
does and an increase amount of people
have lived for three generations in this
informality and when this gets
exacerbated and criminalized it will
pour water on all of Africa's
aspirations so let Africa not follow the
rest of the world in creating large
slums major conflict and crisis in
cities before it solves it at Africa
leapfrog ahead sort out its cities and
create intrusive cities for all